what would make
america safer okay 99
of america who has license to carry or
99 of america who doesn't own a piece of
gun not not a single gun
i'd say the former uh yeah
yeah because i've asked that i've asked
a question before on my show i said i
called the big red button question i
said
what if you live in a world where if you
push through you had a red button right
here if you push this red button all the
guns disappear
would you or would you not push the
button and people when they ask me would
i push it but not say no
and the reason why i wouldn't push the
button is because that button doesn't
remove
guns are not violence guns are
a tool that is utilized by people who
want to commit violence
and so from that perspective i wouldn't
push that button because sure i mean i
do
i've done a little mma you know i work
out i try to take care of myself
so a couple of guys show up and try to
do harm to me i could probably take care
of myself but what about my mom
what about my grandmother what about
people who are more vulnerable
who are in positions who will
legitimately become
targets because they are seen as weaker
i think
a world where be don't have those
firearms i believe the criminals would
become more emboldened
that's why they called the great
equalizer yeah you know the great
equalizer would
allow a grandma or a woman to be safe
going up against the guy who's twice her
size saying hey if you want to do
anything
you know i don't want any problems can
you just leave my house exactly and uh
do you think the argument of of
of getting rid of guns gun control do
you think it's creating more momentum
today or do you think it's actually
losing momentum as an argument
man i struggle with this so much because
i know there's so much missing like
prior to us coming part of me coming on
here i was working on a video response
um to a guy's name i think his name his
name is igor
volsky or something like that and he's
the executive director of a group called
guns down america
um and they they they basically stop
short of saying they want to ban all
guns but that's essentially what they
want to do
um and he did a video titled three myths
about guns about gun control
and he went on and talked about how the
republicans got up and lied about this
bill that just passed the house with
respect to
um universal background checks and
i see these things and you know it's
placed under uh
this is politics now and they have a
million followers
um and i know there are tons of people
who are going to see this video who
don't know anything about guns to begin
with and then they're going to get this
information and they're going to be
misled about the truth of it
so then my little black ass has to come
up here put together a video to counter
that information
with objective information um but then
i i do i do great numbers but i don't
know if i can outdo
the platform like this is now and then
all of the other platforms that have
millions of followers and then you have
a ton of celebrities who are anti-gun
openly anti-gun about things
um like how do i combat that and so but
then you there's another argument that
says well
when you tell people what they can't
have they want it more
right so when you have joe biden get up
there and saying that he wants he wants
to ban
ar-15s and he wants to have uh buy uh
buy back programs for those ar-15s to
have you turn them in or register them
and so forth and so on i can see how
that can then cause
an effect where people want to go out
and say you know what no i'm going to go
and buy these things
um but more than that what i think
really did it honestly was kovit
i think kovid was the biggest driver
largely because
it forced people to confront their
vulnerability in a way that they never
really had to before
and with respect to their dependency on
the government i am not anti-government
i'm just limited government i just like
my government to be
as big as it technically kind of has to
be in order to get certain things done
but i still want it as small as possible
and so what i think happened is when
when you were seeing people get up there
i mean yeah people in doubt they have
our leaders in dallas saying you know
cops aren't going to be coming out
for certain phone calls right i mean
they were seeing the mayhem that was
going on in the streets you had
literally whole sections of seattle
being taken over by people
so when people started to see this and
they realized no i can't just pick up
the phone and call the cops and say hey
come here and deal with this problem
you don't have ubereats protection on
demand and so they're like you know what
i gotta i gotta learn to do this myself
kind of like me when who
oh yes i am the son of an executive chef
but i am not a cooker
but when ubereats stops working for a
couple days and i can't order food
that's what i'm have to do i'm gonna
have to learn how to cook that's right
and so
so a lot of people realize immediately
you oh wow like
i'm on my own here even people who are
radically anti-gun
because that reality trump any ideology
that they may have i hate the fact that
the whole
firearm conversation is even politicized
should not be politicized
shouldn't but it is the fact that it's
so cleanly divided down the middle
between
democrats and republicans or liberals
versus conservatives
is insane to me but here we are and it
is what it is
so to answer your question in short i
think it does a little bit of both
i i think i think some of the rhetoric
causes people to buy guns but then i
think
more so it it misinforms people
and causes them to vote for things that
i think are to their disadvantage
with respect to the issue of guns in
this country because they don't
know there are so many people who
literally think we don't have background
checks for guns
because of the way that they talk about
background checks
because there's a distinction between
background checks and universal
background checks
a lot of people don't know that but when
they do a poll they don't ask
are you in favor of universal background
checks no they say are you in favor of
background checks
it's like well yeah my favorite
background checks but the issue isn't
that simplistic
it's complicated for reason and the
reason why they call in like to call it
a loophole it's not a loophole
it was purposely designed not to include
this segment
of gun buyers purposefully but they
don't they don't say it like that
and so it's these people who become
misinformed on the issue
and then have a false sense of
information
when they come and talk to someone like
me about the issue
and so then i have to almost kind of
re-educate
then rehab that conversation so if you
like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye